we humans are so sensitive to to
nonverbals
that were actually seduced by them and
we don't even understand why so here's a
collection of mobsters from the 1920s
through the 1950s let's look at the
nonverbals and see what they tell us
[Music]
so here's a photograph of Bugsy Siegel
and just from the outfit he's wearing we
can tell just how narcissistic he was
how important it was to look right to
look sharp and yet if we look closely at
his face
we know he's worried about something
even at at about three weeks of age we
know that babies will focus on the eyes
and the glabella interestingly enough
Botox affects this area and there's
actually ample research now that it
affects relationships because we can't
pick up on the behaviors we look at
photographs of these other guys and we
make them bigger than they really are
and here if we were to block the face
you notice how this gangster is giving
himself a self hug he's insecure
he's just been arrested they're not
these mythical figures they're just like
anybody else they just have a gun to
hurt you with
one of the things that stands out is how
often they looked very stoic and they
did this on purpose they knew that these
photographs would be published and one
of the things that they wanted to convey
was that they were not a rap and so in
their photographs you see this very
stoic look not very friendly not very
kind the tough-guy that they've always
been invariably you see things that give
them away here you see a gangster he's
been arrested and he's pulling up on his
socks and what's interesting is how
often we pull up on our socks because
we're ventilating ourselves the skin
overheats especially around the legs and
the feet and so we we ventilate that way
some situations are so painful here we
have a mobster under arrest and you
notice that his eyes are closed he's
pinching the top of his nose and this is
a universal behavior that I really don't
like the situation I'm in or what I'm
looking at most often when we don't like
something the may Salas muscle the
muscle right above the nose we tend to
wrinkle it but we don't realize we're
doing it sometimes here's one of the
mafiosi on trial and they may pretend
that they're tough and they may pretend
everything is fine but when you look at
his attorney and you see those
compressed lips the corners down he
knows that my guy's going to prison and
the nonverbals clearly reflect that you
often see people testifying before
Congress and you see a lot of lip
compression that's because of stress and
when we look at faces we don't realize
how often we're giving information away
as in this photograph where you see the
furrowing of the glabella you see the
purse lips this guy really doesn't like
the situation he's in and so they're
tough guys that you know they brag a lot
but in the
they always reveal something about
what's going on there's a saying that
you can ruin the most perfect mountain
view by reducing it to the the physics
of light on the optic nerve that's what
I do with a face to the average person
this would seem like hard work but it
really becomes like software running in
the background I don't think about it
it's just something that I'm constantly
doing it at any one time and that's how
I analyze people